on the topic of user data privacy have
you ever read the privacy policy of
websites or software that we use often
things like Facebook or Google or Bing
they're so incredibly complicated and it
feels like these policies are written by
the lawyers for the lawyers and really
not intended for us normal people to
read now as a computer programmer
imagine that you have the task of
enforcing this policy on millions of
lines of source code worse there are ten
thousand other developers who are in
your team that are also writing programs
now we know how hard it is to write a
program that doesn't have any bugs and
this these sort of bugs are very hard to
catch that might put the users privacy
at risk
so today compilers help us find some
bugs but these are the bugs that result
in crashes or null pointers or buffer
overflows they're very they do not help
us catch the bugs that make sure that
the user's data is safe and so this was
a problem that we started looking on and
what we found was that there's really no
common language between the lawyers that
work on the policy and the developers
that write source code and so one of the
first things that we did was we created
a language for the lawyers to specify
the policy in this is a language that
the computer can understand and then we
went ahead and created a new compiler
that can check all the source code that
people have already written and identify
potential bugs that might be lurking in
it in the process we actually improve
users privacy and check millions of
lines of source code in very little time
and ensure that going forward these
programs uphold the users privacy and
follow whatever compliance and policy
that the lawyers and regulators have set
up